basically you can see we've got three
variables three equations we want to
find out what XY and z are and you
probably learned a lot of other
techniques like the elimination method
and you know the graphing method and
substitution method but now what we're
doing is we're going to write this as an
Augmented matrix and what that means is
I'm just using the coefficients the
numbers in front of the variables but
I'm also adding on these solutions here
on the right so you can see what I'm
doing here I'm just writing down the
coefficients 3x is 3 1 y is 1 negative 1
Z is negative 1 and the answer is 4 ok
and this is our Augmented matrix now
remember you can interchange okay any
two rows okay so you can you know switch
them you can multiply any row by a
constant multiple as long as it's not 0
so you multiply through by 2 or 10 like
that and you can add any row to any
other row ok so what we're going to do
is we're going to start by trying to get
0 in this lower left-hand corner and the
way I'm going to do that is I'm going to
multiply negative 3 times Row 2 and I'm
going to add it to Row 3 I'm going to
put the answer in Row 3 now it's good to
write down you know what you're doing in
case you want to go back and check your
work in case you made a mistake or you
just want to review you know what you
did so that's why I'm doing that and so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to say
alright we know that the first row is
not changing so I'm just going to
rewrite that ok and we know that the
second row is not going to be changing
but the third row is so we're taking
negative 3 times Row 2 plus Row 3 that's
0 so negative 3 that gives you 3 plus 1
is 4 negative 3 times 2 is negative 6
plus negative 1 is negative 7 negative
18 plus 4 is negative 14 ok great so now
we've got 0 in this lower left-hand
corner now just to tell you where we're
heading with all this what we really
want is we want 0 here 0 here 0 here we
want ones on the diagonal and we want
zeros here and what we want is that we
want our answers right there
so this way we're going to be all done
we're going to have Z is equal to blank
right y is equal to blank and X is equal
to blank now if you want to see this on
the calculator I'll show you at the end
of this video how you can do this row
reduced echelon form using your ti-83 or
eighty-four so stay tuned if you're
interested in seeing how I do that to
check your answer or just to do it in a
quicker fashion but let's go ahead and
go through two examples this first
example we've already got zero here okay
so we're looking good now we want to get
zero here okay in this position so way
I'm going to do that I was going to
multiply negative one times Row one I'm
going to add it to Row two and I'm going
to put the answer in Row two okay so if
I do that let's see so this top row is
really gonna stay the same the bottom
row is really gonna stay the same so I'm
just copying those down and you want to
be careful don't make a little
arithmetic errors okay so negative 1
plus 1 gives us 0 negative 1 plus
negative 1 is negative 2 negative 1 plus
2 is 1 a negative 4 plus 6 is 2 ok so
now you can see we've got zeros here and
here now I want to get 0 here okay so
the way I'm going to do that is I'm
going to combine the second and the
third rows together so we're gonna do
let's see we're going to do 2 times Row
2 plus Row 3 and we're going to put the
answer in Row 3 okay so let's see if we
can do that so we've got 1 1 1 & 4 right
and let's see the this second row is
also going to stay the same
ok but the bottom row when we multiply
this by 2 this is negative 4 plus 4 is 0
this is going to be 2 times 1 is 2 plus
negative 7 is negative 5 2 times 2 is 4
plus negative 14 is negative 10 and we
got it so now you can see we've got
zeros in this lower left-hand corner
what we really want now is to get zeros
here and as well as ones on the diagonal
so let's say I be strategic here let's
go ahead and multiply this third row by
negative 1/5 so negative 1/5 times Row 3
answer in Row 3 so if we do that let's
see what's that going to give us let me
move over here so a little bit more
space okay so what we have is 0 0 1 & 2
all right so that's good so you can see
that Z is equal to 2 so let's go ahead
and copy down what else we have left we
have 0 negative 2 1 & 2 and we also have
1 1 1 & 4 now what I want to do here is
I'm gonna try to get 0 I think I'm gonna
try to get 0 well
zero right for this one here I think
that's going to be the easiest so let's
go ahead and multiply let's see we're
going to do 2 times Row 1 plus Row 2
answer is going to go in Row 1 ok so if
we do that let's see what does that give
us this is 0 0 1 2 this one stays the
same this one's going to stay the same 0
negative 2 1 & 2 but here negative let's
see 2 times Row 1 plus Row 2 that's
going to give us a 2 there let's see
this is going to be 2 plus negative 2 is
0 there that's going to give us 2 plus 1
is 3 there and this is 8 plus 2 which is
going to give us 10 there now it kind of
seems like we took a step backwards
because now we have a 2 here we really
want a 1 here but you'll see how this
works out so the next thing is we want
to combine let's say we want to go for 0
in this spot right here so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to combine the
2nd and the 3rd I'm sorry the second and
the first together so that's going to be
negative 3 times let's see negative 3
times oh I said that wrong let's do that
let's combine this third row with the
first row so we're going to do negative
3 times Row 3 plus Row 1 answer and roll
1 now you want to be careful you know
that you don't undo the work that you
did right so that's why I'm being
strategic I basically said you know
let's combine this third row with the
second role because you can see there's
zeros here already so when we add it
it's not going to you know put it back a
constant here it's not going to put a
constant okay besides 0 so let's go
ahead and do that so we've got negative
3 times Row three we're going to add it
to Row one okay so let's go ahead and do
that so what does that give us
that gives us let's see you've got 2 0 0
and this is let's see negative 6 plus 10
which is 4 ok so that's that's looking
good and the rest we're just going to
copy down as they were okay so 0 0 1 & 2
and then now we're going to try to get 0
here in this spot okay so the way we're
going to do that is we're going to
multiply negative 2 times Row 3 did I
say negative 2 negative 1 times Row 3
plus Row 2 answer in Row 2 okay so
with me so far so that way if this is
negative one and we add it to this one
that's gonna make this zero okay so if
we go ahead and do that let's see what
we get we get 0 we get 0 I'm going to
switch back to this easier for me to
write from this side so 0 1 2 and then
we've got let's see this is going to be
negative 1 times 1 is going to give us
that's going to be 0 here negative 2
plus 2 is going to give you 0 here
negative 1 that's going to give you
negative 2 0 and then the top role is
the same okay so if you're with me so
far ok you can see we've gotten zeros in
the upper right hand corner we've got
zeros in the lower left hand corner now
all we want is ones on the diagonal like
so ok so the way we do that is we're
going to multiply it Row 2 times
negative 1/2 and put the answer back
into Row 2 and we're gonna multiply the
top row Row 1 times 1/2 and the answer
is going to go in roll one so if we do
that let's see run it out of some space
here but let's see it's going to be
right here we've got 1 0 0 & 2
ok this one's going to be 0 1 0 0 and
this one's going to be 0 0 1 2 so now it
seemed like it took a lot more work than
when you just do the Gaussian
elimination with back substitution but
now you're done because you can see that
Z is equal to 2 y is equal to 0 and X is
equal to 2 so our answer is going to be
2 0 2 if you want to check your answer
you just go ahead and put those values
back in for XY and Z and make sure that
it makes all these equations